yo what's up everybody Matuidi here with
another Dark Souls 3 lore video this
video is going to be a lot less formal
and a lot less professional than my
other or videos it is going to be more
speculative and more kind of what I
think happened not necessarily based
directly on item descriptions obviously
influenced by them but there's going to
be much more speculative than my normal
lower series this is going to be similar
to the aldrich extra video since this is
the your extra video filled with stuff
that I couldn't quite fit in the normal
your lore video because it would have
gotten too speculative and I wouldn't
have been focusing on the story of your
alright so let's get into it I think
there are too many dark souls 2
references to just be a throwback or a
nostalgia fanservice play so in the
video I talked about how the flames of
chaos from dark souls 2 Zelly employs
were similar to be profaned flame in
addition to this there's also Gilligan
ladder Smith who is found at the profane
careful if you didn't know at the
Brooklyn capital bonfire the body that
gives you the stretch out I think is the
gesture is Gilligan ladder Smith and
there's a bunch of ladders around so you
know it's Gilligan ladder Smith this was
a character from dark souls 2 he's an
NPC so this along with the flames of
chaos similarities and the Oracle
similarities makes me believe that Allie
employs and Erica are one of the same
and the area below alien voice would
have been the profane capital and the
flames of chaos and dark souls 2 are now
called the profane flame in Dark Souls 3
the propane flame doesn't really have an
origin that we know of it kind of just
has been all the way up to Dark Souls 3
so it would make sense for it to be the
flames of chaos from dark souls 2 and
Gilligan ladder Smith along the Oracle
references makes me believe that it's
the same place this would give some more
backstory on the area that you're Miz
from and that he rules over and the
people there moving on to more about
Gilligan ladder Smith since there is a
partial reason for him to be there it's
not purely just because dark souls 2 and
he was an NPC so as I mentioned in the
main Lord video there's a bunch of gold
and silver all around the profane
capital I use this to see that they were
prosperous and while I do think they
were prosperous I also think the people
were very greedy I say this because for
one all the
gold and silver as I said before to
Gilligan laddish Smith was known as a
scoundrel by other dark souls to NPCs
and that he was cheap he was greedy that
type of sentiment about him he also sold
his ladder is a very high price now long
these other two reasons there's also a
ton of rusted gold coins and rusted
coins found throughout the profane
capital on bodies of dead people this
further supports the people being greedy
Gilly ladder Smith greedy and all the
gold and silver greedy so it sounds like
the people that you are ruled over
really liked money now this could be an
influence for the fire from the sky that
burned everybody and I'm gonna hop more
into that right net so why did the fire
from the sky erupt when you're linked
the fire your link the fire to put down
the profane flame so why did a new flame
erupted from this action burning almost
all of the profane capital citizens
alright so let's look at some Dark Souls
history to get a better understanding of
this so when the witch of izalith tried
to recreate the first flame when it was
fading instead she created the chaos
flame which is the source of all demons
and cursed her I think there were her
daughter's we're helping her try to
recreate the first flame so when you try
and do stuff the first flame that is
unnatural it doesn't like it also
humanity is linked to the first flame
endorses one you offered humanity the
bonfires to power them up so that they
could feed off them and you give more
Isis charges at them also when when
linked the first flame he connected a TP
humanity and he wasn't a human so when
he connected the first lame there was a
giant explosion of fire that burned him
obviously and his silver knights
charring them black so both of these
create a sentiment of don't mess with
the fire just stick to the recipe of
humanity however your is definitely not
a human norms a giant and this is the
first time that we know of a giant
linking the fire so giant linking the
fire could cause the fiery explosion
that happened after he linked the fire
that killed all of the Capitals
inhabitants now referencing what I said
earlier the greed of the people might
have also turned off the fire the fire
didn't like that it was being linked by
somebody who was the leader or supported
all these greedy people so to get rid of
these greedy people it create
needed a fire from the sky to Vernon and
maybe it wanted to do that but couldn't
do that really as much under normal
circumstances but because you're almost
a giant not a human linking the fire
this could have created an avenue for
fire to expel a lot of flame out of the
sky and burn the people so that was
basically it for my extra thoughts in
the video this one was a little bit more
rambling a little bit more out there
than my the one side less of a structure
I hope you guys did enjoy it if you want
more serious lore videos that delve into
the items in the backstory of the Lord
more specifically and less speculative
go check out my other lower videos not
the extras the actual lore videos since
those have a lot of it and so my next
video probably is not going to be a lord
of cinder i do want to complete the four
Lords of cinder before i do any other
types of lore videos however this is
going to be more of an explanation video
my next video I want to do the endings
of Dark Souls 3 explained our four
endings and I want to explain each one
of it I have a pretty good understanding
of most of them however one or two
leaving a little bit confused so I want
all of you to watch the video to go to
comments and tell me what you think
about the endings how you would explain
the four endings of Dark Souls 3 tell me
where your thoughts are on them what you
think each one of the means and all that
explained it in the comments and I
really appreciate that I'll try and use
what you guys say to form my opinion on
the endings so that I can explain them
really well in my next video hope you
guys enjoy it thank you for watching
peace out